hi my name's Liz rice you may know me
through my role with the cncf where I am
the chair of the technical oversight
committee
and I am also the chief open source
officer for I surveillance which is a
company very involved in ebpf technology
and we're also the original creators of
the psyllium project
I've done some talks before
introducing what evpf is and how to
write your first ebpf programs and today
I want to take that down the path of
networking and introduce you to some of
the ways that you can use evpf in
networking functionality
now you probably know that ebpf allows
us to run custom code in the kernel we
can write programs
that we load into the kernel
and we have them triggered in response
to events
there's a huge range of different events
that we can use to cause an ebpf program
to run
you'll probably have seen examples
involving system calls
for example the K probe which is the
function entry point to uh well the
entry point to a function that runs when
a particular system call is
called by a user space application
but system calls are really just the
beginning there are many many other
places in a Linux machine where we can
attach evpf
programs
so the typical hello world program that
I would normally write for an
illustration would attach to a system
call like exec ve
and whenever a user space application
calls that system call
exec ve is used to run a new executable
so every time user space for example you
type a new program name into your shell
you hit return that causes exec ve to
run that program
and we might write a hello world example
that attaches to the entry point the
k-probe of that exec ve function
and that would generate some tracing
every time someone ran a new program
and that tracing would include some
contextual information about the process
that was running that triggered that
call that particular function call that
system call in this case
but
K probes are really just one of many
different types of evpf program there
are a long list of different evpf
program types that we can attach to
different types of events so ebpf is not
just about tracing system calls system
calls are the interface between user
space and the kernel
there's a huge uh wealth of other places
where we can attach evpf programs
another illustration of that is this
diagram from BCC so this is a whole set
of
um ebpf based observability tools and I
think Brendan Greg was probably
responsible for this diagram
the point of showing this is to
illustrate a huge range of different
parts of the system that can be
instrumented using evpf and today we're
mostly going to concentrate on that
green box in the middle that is really
about networking related activity
another way we can look at the range of
different events that we can hook into
is with perf list
bring up my screen we can ignore the
code at the top for now and I'll just
run perf list and you'll see a huge
number of different types of events that
we can instrument with perf and
there's just lots and lots of them
so
I hope that gives you a sense that there
are a lot
of places a huge surface to which we can
attach evpf programs
there's a huge set of network related
events where we can attach evpf programs
I won't have time to cover all of them
uh but let's try and introduce ourselves
to a selection of networking events and
how we might use them to build Network
related functionality using ebpf
so the first place to start would be
with K probes there are lots and lots of
functions that relate to networking
every time we call into at the entry or
exit from any function in the kernel we
can trigger an ebpf program we can
attach it using a k-probe or okay rep
probe for the exit and as an example we
can use the kernel function that gets
called when a TCP connection is set up
so this is going to be the sort of hello
world example for networking
I'm going to be using the BCC framework
which is a good place to start if you're
familiar with python it makes it very
easy to write your user space code it
will run the compilation step for you to
compile your BPF programs that are going
to run in the kernel makes it easy to
attach those to events as you'll see
so my user space code starts by reading
and compiling the the evpf functions
that I've written into this C file
network.c we'll look at that in a moment
and it's going to attach a function
that's called TCP connect to the event
that's associated with the entry to
TCP V4 connect
and I've got a little bit of debugging
that's going to tell us when my ebpf
programs are loaded and we're ready to
go
and then my user space code is going to
print out whatever tracing has been
generated by my ebpf code
and let's take a look the function here
is very simple my TCP connect program
simply traces out a message
so let's just take a quick look at the
interface in my container which has a
loopback interface and F0
and the s0 address is 172.17.0.2
so let's
run this code which is very
very straightforward if I can type
there we go
and that tells us it's ready
so first thing to notice is there could
be other TCP connections
um being generated on this machine and
my
ebpf program is going to see all of them
if I run a curl request to that IP
address we saw a moment ago
I'm not expecting this to succeed
because I don't think there's anything
listening for HTTP requests inside that
container but
we can use it to show that it triggers
uh my tracing it triggers my ebpf
program to run
so that's K probes now let's move on to
some more networking specific program
types and the first one we'll look at is
Socket filter
so
I'm gonna attach to a raw socket using
this socket filter program type
and a raw socket sees traffic coming in
and out very close to the network
connection so it's uh kind of closer to
the network interface than the rest of
the networking stack
socket filtering was designed for
observability and it's worth noticing
this we can look at packets and we can
make decisions about whether we want to
pass a copy up to user space for
observability purpose
so the idea is that if you were running
some kind of tracing utility in user
space you'd probably want to trace a
subset of packets maybe you would want
to trace TCP packets but not other sorts
of networking activity
so let's try an example of this where
we're going to attach to a raw socket
with a socket filter program type and
we're going to filter the copy of
packets that gets sent to user space
so here's my C code so this is the the
evpf program receives a socket buffer
and it's going to step through that
buffer looking first of all at the
ethernet header to see whether it's an
IP packet
if it's not an IP packet it's just going
to return zero then it looks at the IP
header to see what type of request or
what type of packet this is
and here I'm going to trace out whether
it's icmp icmp commonly known as ping
or TCP traffic
and if it's TCP traffic I'm going to
return
-1 and that tells the kernel I want to
send a copy of this packet to user space
I'm going to need to write some code in
my user space side to listen for this
traffic so first of all let's
stop listening to TCP connect events
and instead
we're going to
load a function load that socket filter
ebpf program attach it to a raw socket
and then we're also going to create a
socket
that can where we can receive these
copies of the network packets
and then instead of printing out the
tracing here I'm going to read those
to read those packets
comment that
and indent it
okay
so
as you might recall we're going to pass
TCP traffic up to user space but not
ping
so let's try loading this
so that means if I try and curl to that
address we see data being sent up to
user space
but if I ping the same address
let's just make it slightly wider so it
all fits on one line
we can see that the Ping is
happening successfully but we didn't see
a copy of that in the tracing output
okay
so that's an example of socket filtering
we can only really use this for
observability purposes we can't use it
this is filtering what gets sent to user
space so we couldn't write kernel based
networking functionality using this
now let's look at XDP which stands for
Express data path
now Daniel borkman who is a kernel
maintainer who works at isovalent told
me a great story about how the idea for
XDP came about
and it was essentially saying wouldn't
it be great if we could run ebpf
programs rather than running them on the
CPU what if we could run them on the
hardware itself for networking so when
an inbound packet arrives on the network
interface card if we could inspect that
packet and maybe decide that we're going
to drop it or send it back out the same
interface
if we could do that on the network
interface card it would never have to
spend any resources on the CPU itself
so
if you have a network interface card or
a network driver that supports XDP
you can load vpf programs into that
Hardware itself Hardware offload and
when a packet arrives on that network
interface it can trigger the evpf
program that can make decisions about
what to do with that packet
whether or not to pass it up to the
networking stack or not
not all network cards and network
drivers support XDP so there is support
within the kernel for loading ebpf
programs
as soon as Network packets arrive within
the kernel
so that uh you know we can achieve the
same kind of functionality there is some
performance gain because it hasn't had
to Traverse the networking stack but
it's it's not quite what was intended by
doing that Hardware offload
importantly if we're using containers we
can still run XDP because with the
kernel implementation of XDP
it can be attached to Virtual network
connections as well as physical network
connections
but this is only about inbound packets
if we think about it in the context of a
network card it really makes sense to
process inbound packets as quickly as
possible before we pass them to the CPU
but if the CPU has already handled a
packet and it's on its way out then the
CPU has already done whatever's
necessary
so let's take a look at an example of an
XDP program
so in our user space code this is pretty
straightforward we
can load a function that I've called it
XDP and we attach it to XDP on the
interface F0 which is the same as what
we used for the socket filter before
it's defined up here
also I want to go back to printing out
tracing and we're not
jumping the data anymore
let's take a look at that XDP function
so I've for readability hidden some of
the code inside this is icmpp request
function but it's very similar to what
we just looked at in the socket filter
in case
we're taking the packet we're looking at
the ethernet header and then at the IP
header to see whether or not this is an
icmp ping request and if it is we're
going to trace Trace that out
so let's
build that and load the functions into
the kernel
and then we can run ping again
and in fact I'm going to run this with
just one ping request because it'll be
easier to
read
oh
there we go so we see the Ping request
coming in through XDP so think of that
as the packet arriving at the network
interface and then it gets to the raw
socket where we can see first of all the
request which is destined for an address
ending in zero two
and then we're actually seeing the
response going back through the uh
socket filter because the socket filter
sees traffic in both directions
all right another program type that we
can attach to is related to Traffic
Control
and this is a facility within the kernel
where we can classify or run actions on
network packets
so
we can attach these filters to what's
called queuing disciplines
we can do this in both Ingress and
egress my example is going to use
Ingress
so a packet is going to arrive the idea
of this traffic control is
um you might use it to prioritize
certain types of traffic do traffic
shaping you could also use it for
filtering certain types of traffic
there are lots of different types of
filters that you can add
ebpf programs is one type of filter that
you can attach to these queuing
disciplines
so my example is going to attach we're
going to use the VCC add filter command
to attach a ebpf program to an Ingress
on a queuing discipline
so my
program
again doing something very similar we're
going to trace out the fact we've got a
packet and then we're going to look
through the packet using the same
function as before to check whether it's
a ping request
and in this case I'm going to drop it
this TC act shot says this package is
shot just don't we don't want to pass it
on up the stack
so
TC is gonna
when that ping request reaches this TC
Ingress part of the stack
ping requests are going to get dropped
so I need to load this it's a little bit
more involved here because we need to
create the queuing discipline and add
the filter
and before I forget I need to um make
sure it gets unloaded
at the end
okay
so I'm gonna just start with TC as the
function that we just looked at
and this code here adds the queuing
discipline if it doesn't already exist
and then attaches that ebpf program as a
filter
so let's give this a whirl
and let's run a ping
so we can see the Ping arrived at XDP
it arrived at the socket filter it
arrived in TC Ingress and then we will
have dropped it here so we don't see the
response going back through the socket
filter
this looks like some other packet that's
arrived on that same interface my guess
is that that's probably some kind of Arc
traffic going on we could add some code
to to check that whether that's true
let's run another ping just to
demonstrate yeah we're not seeing those
pings
being responded to 100 packet loss
we're successfully dropping traffic
using TC
but we don't just have to drop
packets we can also modify them and we
can even make decisions about sending
them through different interfaces
so
in the next example what I'm going to do
is respond to that ping request so
rather than dropping it I'm going to
convert the request into a response
that means that the Ping request instead
of having to go all the way up the
networking stack to user space to get a
response that then comes back through
the networking stack I'm going to create
that response within the TC Ingress
filter
okay so I have a function to do this
called TC ping pong which we're going to
load instead of the function we just saw
that dropped the packet
and ping pong is here
if it's not a ping request we will
return okay which says just do whatever
you are planning to do with this packet
if it is a ping request
we're going to swap the source and
destination addresses both for the Mac
addresses and the IP addresses
because we want the packet to go back to
whoever sent it to us
we need to modify the type of the
message that this is saying this is a
response rather than a request hidden
within this function it's also updating
the itmp checksum in the header
and then we have to do something maybe a
little bit special here what we're going
to do is say throw away the original
packet we don't want you to forward the
original request on up the networking
stack so we're going to be responding
with this TC act shot which is what we
used to drop a packet but before we do
that we clone a copy of the packet the
socket buffer
and we tell the kernel that we want to
send that socket buffer through actually
the same index that it arrived on
so let's
give this a try
and that's loaded
so we're hoping to see successful ping
responses this time and we did that was
pretty quick we saw the packets
responded zero percent packet loss
and what we could see there packet the
request comes in XDP it goes through
socket filter gets to TC
uh TC looks at the uh the message but
gives us a little bit more information
about that that message
and then we can see the response which
is destined for address ending in one
being sent back out through the socket
filter
now you might say that's not super
convincing how do we know that the
packet didn't go up through the full
Network stack
one way we can check is to use that perf
utility to trace out networking related
events that happen as those ping
messages Traverse a networking stack
so instead of just sending ping directly
I'm going to send it with perf Trace
and I'm interested in all the network
events
and I'm going to send it to an output
file called let's say with TC
and then I want to run ping I'll send it
once and we're sending it to the same
dress address as before
so that's given us exactly the same
tracing that we saw before
but if we look at that file
with two TTC
we can see a number of different
networking events that were generated as
those packets were well as the Ping
packet was received and then the
response was generated and sent out
I ran that earlier without TC and this
is the result and we should see that the
results without cc is a little bit
longer than with
yeah and we should see it starts with
the same calls
and
we're missing out on some network
interface RX calls here so that's
telling us that something further up the
stack that was receiving packets
we don't need to call that because the
packet never gets that far
so hopefully that has given you an
illustration of how we can use ebpf
networking functionality to bypass parts
of the networking stack and achieve
performance gains
and this is one of the reasons why evpf
is so powerful for cloud native
networking
in kubernetes we run our application
code in pods those pods have their own
typically have their own networking
namespace separate from the host's
networking namespace
and in each of them there's a separate
tcpip stack
so imagine a packet destined for our
application running in a pod it arrives
at the physical interface to the host it
traverses the whole IP stack on the host
then gets passed out through the virtual
ethernet connection to the Pod where it
goes through the pods networking sack
with eppf we can bypass a lot of the
host networking stack because we can see
the address that that packet is destined
for we know that that is one of the pods
because we're a kubernetes cni and we've
been in we've been responsible for
setting up those endpoints so we know
the packet is destined for the Pod and
we can send it straight to the
appropriate virtual ethernet interface
that makes networking significantly
faster and there's a really great blog
post about cni benchmarking on the city
and website that you might want to check
out for more details
another huge advantage of evpf is that
it's instrumenting the kernel and we
don't have to instrument individual
applications we don't have to change
applications or make any configuration
changes
contrast this with a sidecar model where
we typically we typically use a cycle
model for a lot of observability and
security and networking purposes
now a sidecar needs to be injected as a
container into each pod that needs
instrumenting
and to get that sidecar container into
the Pod there has to be a yaml
definition for it
you typically
inject that yaml automatically through
some kind of process maybe admission
control or maybe during your cicd system
but that yaml has to be defined
contrast that to an evpf enabled tool
where the ebpf programming is loaded
into the kernel and gets access to any
events regardless of the the Pod or the
application
so we don't need to modify our pods in
order to use ebpf to
for observability purposes for security
purposes and even for networking
purposes that we might otherwise push
into a sidecar
if we think about networking in
particular that creates a lot of really
cool capabilities
so the fact that we can inspect packets
gives us some really powerful
observability tools that are really
um performance that can be mapped to
other aspects like kubernetes identity
so we can have really detailed uh
mapping between what network packets are
flowing and which kubernetes pods and
services they relate to we can get some
really in-depth security forensics from
this information
we can use the ability to drop packets
or to modify them to create network
policies we can do encryption in eppf
these are all really great benefits for
security
and the fact that we can send packets to
we can change the destination for a
packet allows us to create all sorts of
interesting Network functionality
um things like load balancing routing
services and particularly interesting I
think is the idea of an evpf enabled
service mesh
and if that's something that you're
interested in do come and speak to us
about psyllium
abpf is enabling the next generation of
service mesh
because we don't have to instrument the
pots that make up those services in
order to add these service mesh
capabilities
so I hope that's given you
insight into why I'm so excited about
evpf and how we can use it particularly
from networking related functionality
if you're
interested in writing your own evpf
programs my GitHub repo has some
starting points
if you're interested in writing evpf
programs I would thoroughly recommend
getting involved in a project such as
psyllium we have lots of issues marked
as good for good first issues so do you
come and check those out
I hope that you're going to have lots of
questions for me I'm pre-recording this
now but I will be online and looking
forward to speaking with you